it's an Iranian on a American asset that
is in doubt as to who motivated it in
terms of was it officially sanctioned or
was it a rogue attack whatever it is it
was Iranian how we go forward from here
has to be strategic and smart as an in
close alliance with our our allies that
we have a common interest in the region
we know that the high tension wires are
up there and we must do everything we
can not to escalate the situation but
also to make sure that our our personnel
and the region are safe military action
and one thing that I can say that I was
just talking generally but in terms of
what I can say about the meeting because
it was a classified meeting in terms of
what we were told but on every occasion
that we are engaged with the
administration in terms of our national
security we make it very clear that in
order to get engaged in any and any
military activities we must have a new
authorization of use of military force
at AUMF that that is clear in our caucus
I think even among some Republicans but
I certainly do not speak for them but
also with our Democratic colleagues
state Senate madam Speaker he personally
convinced basically intelligence using
that this was an Iranian attack on an
American asset operating legally
your space yes have you received any
sort of response for you request for a
second to home everything well they have
said that they will do that but briefing
we had this morning as for the time that
I was there they had increased the
number of people who were in the meeting
that to be briefed and therefore they
decrease the level of of information
that they gave us at one point they then
cleared the room but by then I had we
had our our gun safety events that I had
to be at so I don't know what they gave
after I left but it was well into the
well into the briefing so what will they
give to a broader I think I don't know
how much more than is in the public
domain but nonetheless we want to be
current and we want the confirmation of
it and that is that our members of
Congress who have to make decisions are
fully briefed on what the prospects are
and what the possibilities are and what
the choices are
no I didn't say anything they didn't say
yes and and say no we just made our
statements talking about the escalation
are you a particular action to them no I
don't know what the options the
Department of Defense has given to the
president he knows but he did not share
that with us I hope that's right and
that's what we tried to look like three
things to remember we must and this is a
dangerous situation we're dealing with a
country that is a bad actor in the
region we have no illusions about Iran
in terms of their ballistic missile
transfers about who they support in the
region and the rest so we have an
untrustworthy adversary a the high
tension wires are up in the region for a
lot of different reasons
some bilateral in the region some
multilateral some religious whatever it
is the high tension wires are up and
third we must act in a way that does not
that that does deescalate and does not
escalate the tensions and the situation
there and again I come right back to
where I began that phrase we must be
fully engaged with our allies as we go
as we go forward I'm hopeful that that
you're right about what Senator
McConnell said about what the
president's response might be but I have
no idea they may have had their own
conversation but that that would
measured by what measure we'll see but
it is
[Music]
before taking any action I cannot really
predict what actions the white house
will take they did consult with us today
or inform us we had opportunity to share
our thoughts with the administration the
president said have more meetings like
this I don't know what the sequence of
that will be thank you